la fin de la mobilisation était moindre
hier dans toute la France Arnaud
qu'est-ce qu'il faut y voir faut y voir
un essoufflement du mouvement ou une
pause avant la journée du 7 mars
les syndicats eux-mêmes étaient tout à
fait conscients que la mobilisation
serait moindre que celle qui avait pu se
dérouler le samedi et les jours
précédents et les semaines précédentes
ce qui est clair c'est que aujourd'hui
l'objectif principal c'est de 7 mars
c'est le 7 mars parce que le 7 mars
c'est le jour J pour les syndicats ils
vont essayer de faire la démonstration
qui sont en capacité de bloquer un
certain nombre de secteurs essentiels à
la vie du pays et ensuite c'est
qu'est-ce qui se passe après de cette
masse et ça la vraie question c'est de
savoir si il décide collectivement dans
l'unité syndicale qui est la leur de
poursuivre un durcissement de l'action
on voit bien que la stratégie finalement
de j'allais dire de communication des
syndicats c'est de préparer
progressivement l'opinion publique un
durcissement du mouvement face un
gouvernement qui se veut intransigeant
et intraitable quant à sa détermination
amené jusqu'au bout sa réforme donc on
prépare psychologiquement l'opinion
publique ensuite on va voir si
l'opérationnellement on est capable de
bloquer et ensuite on va voir si on peut
bloquer sur la durée et ensuite le
quatrième point c'est le plus important
et je me tourne vers le sondeur est-ce
que l'opinion publique soutiendra des
blocages sur la durée est-ce que
l'opinion publique soutiendra un
mouvement qui se durcisse qui se durcira
dans la durée c'est ce qui s'était passé
en 1995 en fait aujourd'hui vous avez
deux hypothèses c'est soit l'hypothèse
1995 avec ce que l'on sait ce qui s'est
passé ensuite ou l'hypothèse 2010 où là
on a vu que malgré la détermination des
syndicats à l'époque le texte de
présenter par monsieur woert avait été
adopté et on se tentant
ce quasi Arnaud cette journée est plutôt
bien joué c'est vrai qu'il y a moins de
monde c'était attendu les syndicats ont
pris en compte que c'est la scène
parlementaire que c'est plutôt situé la
scène syndicale mais d'un autre côté
être descendu à Albi à une très bonne
idée un très bon coup d'une part Albi
c'est pas n'importe quelle ville c'est
la ville de Jaurès et puis ça prend en
compte une partie de l'histoire une
partie de l'histoire c'est le
département le Jaurès et et ça prend
aussi en compte le phénomène qui est une
vraie rupture par rapport à 95 et
surtout à 2010 ce phénomène de
démétropolisation du mouvement social ou
avant on montait symboliquement sur
Paris et on faisait des des
démonstrations de force là on est dans
des petites villes des sous-préfectures
qui ont vu des très fortes influences
c'est ce qu'on va aussi en plus le
mouvement des gilets jaunes avait plutôt
bien marché maintenant c'est vrai que
par rapport à ce qu'a dit Arnaud quel
est l'état de l'opinion il est quand
même très différent de 95 et de 2010 95
rejet absolu de la réforme Juppé et
soutien très fort à ce moment social qui
a été très court de trois semaines mais
qui a été des qui a été un blocage sans
fin il des journées de manifestations
mais un blocage du pays 2010 beaucoup de
monde beaucoup de monde dans les rues
parce qu'il y avait notamment beaucoup
de journées le samedi mais on avait une
opinion qui a une petite majorité ou un
peu moins soutenait la réforme si on
veut parce que c'était l'idée que parce
qu'on ne pouvait pas baisser les
pensions parce qu'on pouvait pas
augmenter les cotisations salariés
salariale ne restait que dans le cas
d'une réforme très claire ce qui n'est
pas le cas là que les que l'effort
raisonnable de passer de 60 à 62 ans là
on a et vous montrer l'enquête if of
Fiducial pour SUD RADIO un rejet massif
de la réforme et qui ne fait que croître
et la part des Français pas du tout
favorable atteint maintenant quasiment
50% et cela il ne bougeront plus donc
l'opinion montre que le gouvernement a
sans doute perdu la bataille mais il y a
une autre question que je trouve très
intéressante il y a aussi une
intériorisation qui n'a pas bougé non
plus à deux tiers que la loi sera votée
que la loi sera app et que le
gouvernement ne reculera pas donc il y a
cette tension et le 7 mars va peut-être
tranché ce ne gordien cette mars le pays
à la règle comme l'a demandé Jean-Luc
Mélenchon comme la souhaitée Jean-Luc
Mélenchon après est-ce qu'on rentre dans
une logique de blocage du pays très dur
ou est-ce qu'on va avoir une succession
de journée qui ont été relativement
indolore pour les Français
on va revenir peut-être sur ce ce
sondage parce que vous dites 66% enfin
vous dites c'est votre sondage 66 %
quand est-ce qu'elle sera votée et
appliquée alors ce qui est intéressant
c'est que quand on regarde le détail par
partie en majorité dans tous les parties
lèves les sympathisants pensent qu'elle
sera votée appliquée sauf à la France
insoumise oui et encore la France
insoumise au début du mouvement il y
avait une petite majorité des lecteurs
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui disait
finalement Emmanuel Macron ne lâchera
pas là on voit les faits mais la France
insoumise c'est pas tout le pays c'est
moins que c'est le moins que l'on puisse
dire et c'est pas c'est pas celui-là
mais là c'est sur la femme bien sûr
ce que pensent les militants de la
France insoumise ce sont des
sympathisants mais ce sont les seuls à
penser que la réforme ne sera pas votée
leur véritable radicalité on va en
parler peut-être tout à l'heure ça aussi
explique la perte de vitesse du jean du
Mélenchon et la France insoumise dans le
cadre de la Nuit pêche dans le regard
des Français qui en ont maintenant ce
qui est très notable aussi parce que il
y a est-ce que la loi sera retiré ou
votée mais même et c'est le signe de
l'échec du gouvernement même les
segments dont on attendait qu'il
soutiendraient cette réforme comme ils
ont soutenu toutes les réformes de ce
type depuis début de l'année Macron les
ordonnances travaillent en 2017 la
réforme de la SNCF en 2018 même c'est la
réforme et minoritaire chez les cadres
de l'ordre de trois quarts une personne
âgée sur deux seulement un retraité sur
deux soutien la réforme est là pour
reprendre les deux phases historiques à
rappeler Arnaud rupture totale avec 95
et avec 2010 ou en 2010 le gros du
soutien à la réforme Sarkozy c'était les
retraités là on voit très bien parce que
cette réforme est vue comme eminemment
injuste et
pas clair les le recul sur la sur
l'adhésion c'est très clairement l'effet
1200 euros qui a été absolument
dévastateur on n'y comprend plus rien et
le le graphique du Parisien hier sur
l'âge de départ selon l'âge d'entrée
mais personne n'est capable de
l'analyser
une adhésion qui a reculé de quatre
points par rapport à la semaine dernière
Arnaud
pourtant c'est que je regardais sondage
de Frédéric c'est qu'en plus on voit par
exemple le monde de l'entreprise les
chefs d'entreprise sont aujourd'hui ORP
de manière plus faible mais aussi sont
quand même défavorables à la réforme
c'est quand même très intéressant de
voir qu'en effet vous avez tout un
ensemble de catégories sociales de
catégories socio-professionnelles qui
aujourd'hui sont hostiles à cette à
cette réforme si vous voulez la
perception vraisemblante cette réforme
c'est il y a deux aspects si vous voulez
le pêche elle pêche au niveau de de deux
paramètres elle est considérée par comme
juste par une grande partie de l'opinion
publique notamment sur la question des
carrières et des carrières longues entre
entre autres ou d'égalité homme-femme
aussi mais aussi elle est vraisemment
perçue de manière diffuse comme
inefficace c'est-à-dire comme elle ne
résoudrait pas le problème sur le fond
et sur la durée le problème la question
des retraites et du financement des
retraites donc si vous voulez à la fois
vous cumulez l'injustice et
l'inefficacité donc vous avez là en
effet quelque part j'allais dire une
forge qui nécessairement rend difficile
l'acceptation de cette de cette réforme
ensuite il y a un autre sujet qui me
paraît important c'est si vous voulez en
effet aujourd'hui l'opinion semble avoir
intériorisé le fait que cette réforme
serait adoptée mais vous savez il y a
quand même toujours dans l'histoire et
de la dynamique des événements parfois
quelque chose qui relève de l'alé ou du
hasard et de la dynamique propre des
événements encore une fois nous allons
voir dans les semaines qui viennent ce
qui va se passer je rappelle qu'en 95
puisqu'on prenait le président de 95 95
au début l'opinion publique n'est pas
défavorable à la réforme elle devient
progressivement elle devient
progressivement défavorable à la réforme
notamment en raison parfois des erreurs
de communication du gouvernement et là
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que la
communication du gouvernement Frédéric
l'a dit est une communication très
aléatoire très incertaine on a changé de
message en permanence pour justifier
cette réforme donc ce qui fait que la
crédibilité de la réforme évidemment
quelque part pêche aux yeux de l'opinion
publique et la Communication Frédéric a
un vrai impact sur les Français dont
l'acceptation d'acceptabilité par nous
les femmes par les Français surprend un
cas historique 2010 c'était extrêmement
clair l'effort était rude de passer à 60
à 62 ans c'était un coup de canif sur
cette réforme de 1980 la retraite à 60
ans complètement sacralisée par les
Français mais la réforme était
extrêmement claire
a été jugé comme efficace il y avait un
contexte d'inquiétude sur les comptes
publics on n'est pas dans ce contexte 95
je reviens aussi en arrière ce que dit
Arnaud est très juste je rajouterais un
point 95 qui a été extrêmement faible ce
qui a été le point faible de la réforme
Juppé c'était que elle était en rupture
avec les promesses présidentielles 95 on
était six mois moins de 6 mois après ils
sont présidentielles on était sur la
France pour tous la facture sociale là
on est sur quelque chose de Rude
s'agissant de l'économie mais c'est vrai
qu'en France la question de la justice
de l'injustice est un point dévastateur
tout très forme qui est perçu comme
injuste et rejeté par les Français ou
dans les graphiques que vous montiez que
vous montriez tout à l'heure Oriane on a
un tiers quasiment un tiers des
sympathisants Renaissance et des
électeurs d'Emmanuel Macron du 10 avril
qui sont défavorables à cette réforme
alors même qu'elle a été annoncée noir
sur blanc pendant la campagne mais on va
parler justement de ce qui se passe du
côté de l'Assemblée nationale puisque
c'est aujourd'hui le dernier jour
d'examen de ce texte bon c'est commence
pas trop l'examen on est un peu coincé
au niveau des articles mais hier il y a
eu encore un une assemblée un peu
électrique des tensions dans l'Assemblée
nationale puisque c'est un ancien député
et pas des moindres Camille il faut aux
poudres
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon il faut croire
qu'elle plane toujours sur le Palais
Bourbon que vous nous le direz après
l'ancien député des Bouches-du-Rhône
depuis Montpellier où il se trouvait
pour la manifestation contre la réforme
des retraites penser ses camarades
communistes de la nu pour le retrait de
leurs amendements avec ce tweet
incompréhensible retrait des amendements
du PCF pourquoi se précipiter à
l'article 7 le reste de la loi ne compte
pas hâte de se faire battre interroge
Jean-Luc Mélenchon fait original c'est
un député de la majorité Sylvain
Maillard qui l'a fait remarquer dans
l'émission l'écoute
oh merci madame la Présidente en vertu
de l'article 100 de notre règlement et
pour la bonne conduite de nos débats on
vient d'avoir un une parole du leader de
la nupes qui met en cause nos collègues
du
communiste on leur disant et en disant
très clairement pourquoi se précipiter à
l'article 7 parce qu'ils avaient enlevé
leurs amendements il est en train de
dire très clairement c'est la nupette
c'est les filles qui fait le blocage
alors moi nous il y en a assez on
souhaite voter on souhaite avancer il
reconnaît qui bloque je demande une
suspension
pour qu'il puisse discuter entre eux et
organiser l'enlèvement de l'ensemble des
des amendements qui bloquent voilà
Mathias on va y avait de l'ambiance et
cet événement à acheter la suite des
débats aussi toute la suite des débats
pendant de longues minutes et animer les
passions regardez cette passe d'armes
entre le député insoumis manuel Bompard
et le ministre du Budget Gabriel Attal
je ne sais pas
si qu'il a trahi un secret monsieur le
ministre ce serait bien que vous cessiez
vos diversions qui visent à nous
empêcher de débattre des différents
amendements que nous avons déposés
monsieur le ministre si vous avez
l'intention que l'ensemble de ces
articles soit débattus il y a une
solution extrêmement simple prolonger
les débats renoncer à l'utilisation du
car 147 ans laissez-nous débattre de
l'ensemble de ce projet de loi et nous
le ferons avec plaisir et Monsieur le
Député Bombard si vous voulez qu'on ait
le débat sur ces sujets là ce n'est pas
un sujet de nombreux deux jours c'est un
sujet d'obstruction c'est assumé par
Jean-Luc Mélenchon lui-même sur Twitter
il dit il faut faire traîner les débats
parce que sinon on va se faire battre
elle nous assumons que l'ensemble des
articles de ce projet de loi sont
importants et donc l'ensemble de ces
articles de ce projet de loi sont à
débattre pourquoi vous nous obliger à
adopter à la hâte en 10 jours en 10
jours un projet de loi sur les retraites
et bah oui monsieur Attal ne comptez pas
sur nous d'accord avec votre sinistre
besoin au final l'article 7 n'est
toujours pas examiné et non les débats
n'ont pas encore atteint à l'article 3
un peu plus de 3000 amendements c'est
par encore les députés de l'examen du
fameux article portant sur le report de
l'âge de départ à la retraite avec le
rythme actuel on imagine mal comment
celui-ci pourrait être débattu d'ici ce
soir
est-ce que c'est une erreur un dmfael
comme dit Gabriel c'est-à-dire un
message qui aurait dû rester privé et
qui s'est retrouvé public
mais est-ce que c'était une erreur ou
est-ce que c'était volontaire de
l'appart j'ai du mal à imaginer que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et commis une telle
erreur non non c'est totalement
intentionnelle de sa part mais c'est
vrai que si vous voulez on est quand
même dans une partie de pour de poker
menteur de toute part dans cette affaire
depuis le début à la fois du côté des
oppositions et notamment de la nups et
de la fille mais également du côté du
gouvernement alors on crie à
l'obstruction certes on peut créer à
l'obstruction mais enfin on est sur une
chaîne parlementaire on connaît un peu
l'histoire du Parlement y obstruction on
en a connu d'autres sous la 5e
République et parfois beaucoup plus
importante donc c'est pas nouveau en
l'occurrence c'est pas une surprise
c'est pas une innovation deuxièmement
clairement aussi il est évident que du
côté de l'exécutif la procédure qu'on a
choisi c'est-à-dire la procédure à
travers l'article 47 heures est une
procédure qui contraint de manière
temporelle le débat et qui rend en effet
parfois un peu difficile l'examen et moi
j'ai l'impression que tout le monde mais
ça arrange tout le monde le fait qu'on
aille pas jusqu'au bout de cet article 7
ça arrange les oppositions parce
qu'elles sont pas sûr bien évidemment et
la France insoumise de leur coup parce
qu'ils savent très bien que
arithmétiquement ça va être difficile de
mettre en minorité le gouvernement mais
comme le gouvernement n'est pas tout
à fait il n'a pas toutes les assurances
on sait jamais ce qui peut se passer
dans un vent on l'a vu l'article 2 il a
été rejeté par le par le gouvernement
donc j'ai l'impression que ça arrange
tout le monde mais le résultat final
c'est que alors que vous avez des
mobilisations sociales qui se passent de
manière apaisée avec des syndicats qui
agissent de manière plutôt mature
aujourd'hui dans le reposition au
Gouvernement sur ce texte vous avez une
Assemblée nationale qui donne une scène
politique en général qui donne un
spectacle qui est très contrasté par
rapport d'une certaine manière avec
l'esprit de responsabilité des syndicats
et la crainte que l'on peut avoir en
effet c'est que infini il y ait un vieux
fonds d'anti parlementarisme qui Renesse
en France vous savez la France est un
pays très anti parlementaire aussi il a
été à plusieurs reprises dans son
histoire et le risque en effet c'est que
finalement on donne l'impression de
voler aux Français le débat dont ils ont
besoin au Parlement et ça en effet c'est
regrettable je pense sur le fond pour
les institutions je partage complètement
ce que dit Arnaud et ça se refait même
dans notre enquête dont on a parlé tout
à l'heure qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
réforme on peut la voir comme la
confrontation de deux scènes la scène
parlementaire va pas revenir sur les
incidents graves de la semaine dernière
ça fabrique de l'anti parlementarisme ça
fabrique chez les Français une forme de
dégoût et en fait d'indifférence et on a
une scène syndicale on a l'impression
que on a retrouvé des manifestations un
peu retour vers le futur c'est à dire
qui se passe bien depuis la rupture de
2015-2016 loi travail ou des incidents
des blackbocks avaient beaucoup choqué
les Français sans parler de ce qui s'est
passé avec les gilets jaunes avec le
saccage de l'Arc de Triomphe ou les
choses sont codifiées se passent de
manière bon enfant et c'est reflété dans
les enquêtes d'opinion on a reposé une
question par poser depuis 2018 sur la
confiance globale vis-à-vis des saints
des syndicats on a une confiance
minoritaire mais latin de 41%, c'est
presque 10 points de plus par rapport à
ces dernières années quand on pose de
manière globale la confiance dans les
parties politiques on a au moins 20
points de moins et c'est vrai que c'est
très intéressant alors je pense que
l'article 2 c'est moins vu par les
Français mais l'irruption du spectre
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a refusé qui n'a
pas voulu être candidat en 2022 après sa
défaite avec son présidentielle qui a
donné sa circonscription à manel Bompard
combien de voix et qui est présent
absent des débats qui cherchent toujours
à rayer des comptes avec le PC faut pas
oublier qu'en 2017 après sa défaite à la
présidentielle Jean-Luc Mélenchon a mis
des candidats et les filles dans toutes
les circonscriptions y compris celle
tenue par le Parti communiste français
donc on est sur des querelles partisanes
qui il est vrai n'intéresse pas les
Français et plus que jamais c'est pas
notre sujet
enracine laupes dans une dans une
opposition brouillonne tribunicienne
face à Marine Le Pen qui apparaît de
plus en plus face avec ses députés RN
entre guillemets sages comme une
alternative mais Arnaud kiki intéresse
finalement est-ce que cette obstruction
se fasse et est-ce que cet article 7 ne
soit pas examiné parce qu'on a entendu
les syndicats depuis quelques jours
demandez est-ce que cet article 7 soit
examiné à ce qu'il y a un vote sur cet
article moi je crois que je tactiquement
je crois que Jean-Luc Mélenchon a raison
je crois qu'il a raison sur le fond
parce que tactiquement je parle pas
politiquement mais tactiquement parce
qu'en effet si vous voulez quand même
qu'on le veuille non si l'article 7 est
adopté on peut considérer que ça aura un
effet psychologique sur lequel donc
après ça va être quand même difficile de
maintenir si vous voulez la mobilisation
si cette article 7 est adopté si on
finit par trouver un terrain d'entente
en commission mixte paritaire au
Parlement donc moi je crois qu'en effet
là de ce point de vue là sur un plan sur
un plan uniquement je veux dire du
rapport de force et de de l'usage du
rapport de force vis-à-vis du
gouvernement l'intérêt malgré tout de
ceux qui sont hostiles à la réforme
c'est d'éviter que l'article 7 soit
adopté là on reste quand même dans une
zone d'incertitude qui malgré tout donne
de la motricité encore à la mobilisation
les syndicats ont un autre avis
manifestement notamment Laurent Berger
mais on peut se poser la question de la
pertinence même Philippe Martin mais on
peut se poser la pertinence de cette de
cette on peut aussi montrer que les
syndicats finalement jouent un rôle en
disant cela aussi d'une certaine manière
parce que ça ça leur donne ça leur donne
une responsabilité supplémentaire et ça
renforce si vous voulez peut-être le
soutien de l'opinion publique par
rapport à des syndicats qui font preuve
j'allais dire de maturité dans cette
affaire un risque de rupture entre la
gauche et le monde syndical non je pense
à parce que aucun n'y a intérêt on a
senti une irritation et le mot est
faible des organisations syndicales
quand il y a eu cette marche des jeunes
du 21 janvier il y a vraiment ces deux
sphères qui ne sont qui ne sont pas
étanches mais
clairement les Français voient plutôt
une opposition entre les syndicats et le
et le gouvernement les partis politiques
de gauche la scène parlementaire compte
mais elle est quand même reléguée
derrière ces mouvements sociaux c'est
manifestation et s'il y a des blocages
comme la même aujourd'hui que Mélenchon
appelle à ce que le pays soit bloqué ça
sera l'oeuvre des syndicats pour les
Français ça sera le oui c'est quand même
si ça sera stimulé et cette opposition
se retrouvera à l'Assemblée dans le
cadre de l'examen de la loi puisque on
sera dans une concomitance et c'est
toujours ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure
entre cette scène parlementaire qui est
peu visible et qui séduit Pelé français
dans le contexte de désordre et voir
avec t-il et une scène syndicale qui est
beaucoup plus claire où on est sur je
dirais la dramaturgie l'affrontement
classique entre un gouvernement qui
présente une réforme et un mouvement
syndical le point par contre qu'il faut
avoir en tête c'est que une histoire
joue pour le gouvernement la dernière
fois que dans ce type de ce type de
quelle figure un gouvernement a reculé
et retiré sa réforme c'est avril 2006
c'est le contrat premier embauche et les
Français n'ont plus ou en moins cette
mémoire en tête et c'est une réforme qui
avait déjà été votée est-ce que les
Français
croient à une possibilité de retrait de
la réforme même après un vote du
Parlement je pense qu'il ne suppose pas
cette question comme cela ils ont
intériorisé que Emmanuel Macron pour
toute une série de raisons sa trace dans
l'histoire son quinquennat qui est quand
même pas bien emmanché si je si je puis
dire ça posture de réformateur le fait
qu'il doit rester au centre je ne peux
pas ne pas reculer mais j'utilise à des
cinq doubles négation et Arnaud a très
très bien dit un mouvement c'est quelque
chose de mouvant il a sa logique propre
quid d'un pays complètement bloqué après
le 7 mars on a vu c'est vrai dans
l'histoire des réformes qui devaient
passer qui était complètement
je dirais complètement attendu qui
finalement ne sont pas n'ont pas été
promulgués c'était l'affaire etc juste
un petit point je regardais un sondage
je sais plus je suis désolé qu'elle
était l'Institut mais un sondage
dimanche dernier ou vous avez quand on
pose la question aux Francis s'il y a
blocage de demain à qui vous en
impliquez la responsabilité une large
majorité semblerait en appliquer au
gouvernement donc ça de ce point de vue
là c'est j'allais dire une arme
supplémentaire pour les syndicats à
partir du moment où on considère que ben
oui la responsabilité du blocage
viendrait plutôt du côté du gouvernement
que des syndicats et ça veut dire que ça
leur donne des arguments pour le 7 mars
ça renforce on doit essayer leur
position
et il faut y aller et plutôt de leur
côté sur je pense que même si c'est
jamais facile dans sa vie quotidienne
quand le pays est bloqué ce qui
souviennent de
95 c'était surtout l'Île-de-France qui
était bon il faut s'en souvenir aussi
mais c'était aussi un soutien et notre
ami Stéphane Rozès avait mobilisé le
conseil de soutien par procuration la
grève par procuration il y avait quand
même toute une série de français du
secteur privé qui était vent debout
contre la réforme mais qui n'ont pas pu
manifester ni faire grève et qui ont
délégué ce pouvoir aux agents et aux
fonctionnaires du service public
[Musique]